[Music]
today we are so excited to talk to you
guys about em have you been there where
you sorry about me and you lose track of
your thoughts what do you do jump around
the room today we're gonna tell you guys
how to let it go so I'll start by
talking about common mistakes that maybe
you've tried to prep for it but as much
as you can it's hard to move on I
remember vividly in the eighth grade I
was cast in my dream role as Annie I
always wanted to be a redhead and had to
wear a wig for it but worth it
the first song comes on this is my go
time but I freeze
I completely forgot the lyrics didn't
know how to start
luckily Katie ty was sitting right next
to me the other orphan and just started
singing along with me patted me on the
back we don't all have Katie ties
standing next to us so what can you do
when you forget your lines one thing
that happens when you're stressed is
your body emits cortisol the stress
hormone the really cool thing about
cortisol is that it blocks out any
activities it deems is unnecessary one
of which being memory recall so if you
get very nervous during a presentation
your body is actually saying uh-oh time
to stop remembering everything great so
what can you do one of the things you
might have noticed me doing my eyes were
jumping around the room when I was
trying to remember what I was gonna say
you shouldn't do that maintain eye
contact it'll actually help you to calm
your thoughts if you're jumping all
around you're taking in a lot of inputs
and your mind is going to get as jumbled
as it already was if not more obviously
there's a creepy level I can't just
start
the whole time that would make everybody
even more uncomfortable
the second thing phone-a-friend and the
audience wants to see you succeed
nobody in the audience is like oh I'm so
excited Cameron forgot the start of the
song this is very comfortable for me I
hope she never starts up everybody at
once don't you feel free to rely on them
for help it's totally appropriate to say
hey remind me what I was just saying or
what was the last slide we were just on
very fine you just move on
the last thing is use your resources you
may or may not have slides around you if
you do it's okay to look back reread
your lines or even just repeat what you
were saying now sometimes it's not that
you forgot what you were gonna say you
said it it just didn't really land so
we're gonna look at a great example from
one how look I get that a lot of people
aren't sure that we're serious about
this I know that we don't exactly have
the strongest reputation on privacy
right now to put it lightly not a great
look conference right after all the
scandals at Facebook based with data
privacy mark decided to be a good time
to make a joke but not everybody was
ready to laugh we learned earlier this
week about how humor can be effective
and as much prep as you do sometimes it
just doesn't land there are a few things
though even though marks joke didn't go
well that mark did do well one was he
maintained the breathing remember that
cortisol I was talking about breathing
helps counteract that it actually
introduces carbon dioxide into your
bloodstream which calms your nerves and
helps you focus the next and these two
kind of go together he didn't apologize
he just moved on apologizing can
actually distract the audience and make
them linger on something it was a
mistake or maybe they didn't even notice
before so they're ready to move on it's
time
you too as well speaking of moving on we
all kind of run out of time or maybe you
guys speak a lot more appropriately
times than I do but when you're running
out of time one thing you can do just
jump to the end don't be afraid to get
to your conclusion offer to the audience
hey I'll answer any questions you have
later now the main takeaways we have
focus yourself use your resources and
just keep going sometimes though it's
not your fault
what if somebody in the audience is
doing something that's actually going to
tell you how to handle somebody like
himself let me tell you all kind of
destruction like this destruction like
this actually happened quite often and
it could happen in different forms for
example there could be interrupting
sounds and sometimes when you are
talking people could just walk in late
or they could have a saying they must
leave early
you've got to love that right and I'm
sure you have run into situations where
there is a technical glitch and it just
doesn't work I know I did sometimes you
just know that technology makes it
possible for people to gain control over
everything except over technology that's
why I think when you're just about to
pay the super important video and it
doesn't play and all you can do is to
say the three magic words
it worked yesterday
so now we all know the symptoms how do
we do with that I offer you five tips
tip number one stay calm don't panic
whenever it happens you're honest and
you let the audience know you are in
total control
rule number two do not apologize
apologizing makes you feel weak it
doesn't have solve the problem instead
direct the audience attention back to
what you are going to say which leads to
rule number three
respond with lightness care next time if
the phone rings when you are speaking
you could pause smile look him in the
eyes and say is that for me people look
at the message a rule number four is
very important walk around and come
closer don't get bogged down by the
problem turn the problem into an
operating to engage and connect with the
audience let's say if someone is having
very distracting side conversations you
can come off the stage walk toward him
just ask hey is there a question or you
have something to share with us that
would be good
eventually through them the five
reconnect and move on quickly reconnect
with what was going on before the
interruption and drum right back into
your phone let's take a look at how this
gentlemen handles a major distraction we
cannot sustain was that my
oh goodness that's alright
all of you know who I am
[Applause]
but I'm sure there's somebody back there
that's really nervous right now don't
you think they're sweating bullets back
there attorney he's he'll do it aces
right he stay calm I keep smiling he
responded with placards by telling the
audience it doesn't matter and he is
showing t audience say we walk around us
no matter what and building connections
by saying You Know Who I am
the next thing is asking the audience
where were we and drive I'm packing to
the soul and move on Obama was lucky
because they had a very friendly
audience but sometimes I'm gonna cover
attacks so maybe one day you become a
politician or Sando comedian or maybe a
news anchor and you have an annoying
aggressive heckler like me but attacks
aren't just that serious they could be
anything from a confrontation in a
meeting where your colleague undermines
you in front of your peers or maybe you
have a really bad boss and they yell at
you and they shame you this kind of
happened to me I was starting a new
project and I went into an introductory
call it's a product manager and as my
job I'm asking a lot of questions right
what I didn't understand was the group
product manager on this
object really needed to get this thing
through politics am i right
so by questioning made it seem like I
would slow this project down and she
yelled at me in front of my entire new
team and my peers it was awful
I couldn't sleep for days afterwards I I
wish I knew what to do in that moment I
wish I knew how to signal that I took
control and that's not okay but instead
I just shrunk into the corner didn't say
anything so now I'm preparing you so
that you don't have to deal with this
what do you do when you get attacked
first thing Keep Calm speak slow all of
our speech has a natural tempo to it
when you're happy and you're calm you
speak a little slower you indicate that
you're in control place when you're
upset and you're and you're flustered
you start speaking more quickly and that
makes people tense and it eventually
leads to a blow up you want to avoid
that the next thing you can do is status
careful it's super easy to just snap
right back at that person and
embarrassing but what that does is it
puts them on the defensive and it makes
them look as bad as it makes them feel
as bad as you felt so help them and help
yourself
by maintaining that relationship and
bringing them on your side towards to
work toward something and the way to do
that is shifting towards process take
the attention away from that conflict
and move it toward something productive
the next steps that you can take
together so now that you know what to do
I have one final ask which is if you see
this happening which I know you all have
not just someone being yelled at but
some really tense conversation going on
now you know what to do to save
everyone's face
in that situation and I promise you they
will be forever grateful wrapping up
things happen you can prepare as much as
you want for a presentation something's
gonna pop up that you're not expecting
if you were to take away anything from
this presentation it's these three
things first three keep calm take
control of the situation whether it's
through humor or stating shared goal
we're all human we know mistakes happen
do we understand last move on
don't let your mistake ruin your
presentation or worse ruin your
relationships so the next time something
comes up with that are there any
questions
[Music]